and now as we were just discussing the
Labour Party is consumed by the contest
to choose its next leader and deputy
leader but last summer it was the
leadership race of the Conservative
Party that we were all focusing on and
in that contest Boris Johnson beat
Jeremy hunt to become prime minister
quite bits change since then mr. hunt
the former Foreign and Health Secretary
has since become chair of the House of
Commons Health Committee he joins us now
in the studio
thank you very much being with us what
are you searching and congratulations on
the chairmanship thank you I mean you
want to focus in particular on maternity
safety on the health of babies and
mothers as well what what exactly is it
that you're so concerned about well we
have about four babies dying every
single week across the NHS and this is
by the way not something that's unique
to the NHS this is something that's the
case in healthcare systems across the
world and these are awful awful
tragedies I don't think anyone can think
of something that would be more
traumatic I've got three young children
myself and it is literally the worst
thing that anyone can go through to see
their own child die but the truth is
that what we've never properly cracked
is how we learn from those mistakes how
we make sure that when those terrible
things go wrong what tends to happen at
the moment is people are worried about
lawyers and they're worried about
getting sacked they're worried about the
reputation of their hospital and their
unit and these incredibly ethical
doctors and nurses who want to do
nothing more than be completely open and
transparent about what happened and if
they made a mistake say so and make sure
the lessons are learned find the system
makes it absolutely impossible for them
to do that so what can be done that we
need to well we need to change the
culture so that at the moment in in most
professions your profession my
profession our bosses understand that
sometimes we make mistakes and if you
make a very serious mistake
well you might lose your job if you're a
reckless completely idiotic then of
course you might lose your job but if it
was just the kind of ordinary human
mistake that that we all make then you
understand that
happens to us all and we learn from it
in medicine we don't really have that
clear division because when someone dies
it's such a big deal and so sometimes
even the ordinary human mistakes get
elevated into something where someone
has to lose their job and if that
happens then of course people aren't
going to be open about the mistakes and
medicine is really the only profession
where the price of something going badly
wrong is is often that sadly you have
these tragedies and that's what we have
to change it's interesting how you seem
to be paint your picture we're
relatively small human mistakes can lead
to these kind of devastating
consequences and it does feel to me like
you know we often talk about the big
scanners on the NHS but if you're
thinking about women giving birth in
hospital the kind of aftercare you
receive these small mistakes small
problems seem to be almost commonplace
almost accept it that you might not see
the same Midwife that you know your
postnatal care may not be what you're
expecting for that people won't
communicating you with you during the
birth process then why are we getting
these things so wrong well I think it's
important to say that the vast majority
of NHS care is totally safe in fact the
Commonwealth Fund said that we are the
safest health care system in the world
but we're also the most transparent
health care system in the world we care
passionately about our NHS it's it's the
number one issue I see it's now
overtaking brexit as the issue that's
most of concern to the public and I
think this is something you know
interests could blaze a trail on but if
we're going to do that we have to
recognize that when those human mistakes
are made we have to allow doctors and
nurses the space to learn from those
mistakes and the right reaction is it's
easy to scapegoat someone but actually
the right reaction is to understand why
the mistake happened and then to design
a system so that it can't happen again
it's interesting listening to you
because of course you're not someone who
is just a observer at the Health System
when you were health secretary from 2012
to 2018 so some of our viewers won't be
thinking what sounds great that you're
calling for these changes but why on
earth didn't you do it when you were a
secretary well it did make a number of
changes and I'm incredibly proud as to
the way the NHS has reacted since we had
the tragedies of mid staffs and walking
Bay and I don't
any doubt that we are much much more
transparent about things when they go
wrong so if you don't admit stats for
example that happened over a four-year
period that was the really the shocking
thing about it took so long for
something to happen and now we have the
new CQC system we've had 40 hospitals
put into special measures so there's
transparency now when things go wrong
with a hospital level but I still think
when it comes to what happens for an
individual doctor a nurse we need to do
much more to support clinicians on the
front line so they can be open and we
can turn the NHS into this giant
learning organization which is what it
really needs to be ok we've been talking
about health and you of course were
former health secretary also the former
foreign secretary and recently we've
seen some really horrific scenes
happening in Italy in Syria and families
dying children dying war crimes being
committed with the use of barrel bombs
with hospitals being targeted
why has the international community
failed so comprehensively with Syria and
is this something that we should feel a
sense of shame over well first of all
I'm very grateful that you have raised
this issue because it seems to me with
coronavirus and with you know all the
other issues going on around the world
this is like the Forgotten tragedy
that's happening at the moment and it is
absolutely appalling human tragedy and
remember how much people in it lip have
already been suffering for the last few
years the reason is because Western
foreign policy to Syria has been
inconsistent one moment we are fighting
a sad we're saying we're going to remove
him we're saying that that's how Syria
has no future with a sad at the helm the
next moment we're saying we're out of
here
we don't want anything to do with it and
whilst we have that inconsistency then
I'm afraid the potential for these
tragedies to go on and on increases what
do you make of the current policy on it
well I understand why it is that Western
public opinion wants to disengage with
the Middle East it's a long way away we
see these terrible tragedies of our own
soldiers being killed in Iraq and Afghan
Stan but in truth we are always gonna
have to have some presence in the Middle
East it's absolutely essential to our
national interests Britain is one of the
most engaged countries of Europe in in
the Middle East and I personally thought
it was a great shame when we abandoned
the Kurds who have been fighting
alongside us for very many years so I
think it's really about consistency
about recognizing that you know when you
have destabilizing activity by countries
like Iran if we blow hot and cold on
these things then that gives them the
opportunity to run rings around us do
you think is this one of the things when
you look back anything I wish I'd done a
bit more when I was one secretary well I
think Britain and I don't take credit
for this myself because you know it was
a it was a joint effort but Britain did
a great deal I mean we were one of the
countries for example that organised the
evacuation of the white helmets from
Syria that happened in my first month as
foreign secretary and we made an
absolutely decisive intervention that
got them taken out of Syria we are not
making that made to slice some
interventions now well I hope that
brexit will be a moment when we can
start focusing more on the outside world
because one of the things that's my
biggest surprise as foreign secretary
was when you go around the world all
these different countries other
countries have a whole lot more respect
for Britain than we sometimes seem to
have for ourselves and they want us to
be involved in the world interesting now
I want to ask you about another case and
the case of answer coulis
who is the driver the American driver
who is wanted in the UK over the death
of her done the teenage teenage boy who
died very sadly now she fled to the US
claiming diplomatic immunity it since
emerged and Sky News has confirmed that
she's a former CIA operative now at the
time she wasn't at the time the death
it's important to say and do you think
that has any bearing on why the US has
been refusing to extradite well it may
have a bearing on it and you know I
don't know the truth of these things
because I'm not foreign secretary
anymore
but I still think it is total
utterly unacceptable that she is not
facing justice in the UK and if anyone
is questioning that I think we just need
to ask what would have happened if the
boot had been on the other foot if a
British diplomat had been involved in a
road accident in the United States where
someone had died and had fled on a
private plane back to the UK and was
evading justice I don't think president
Trump would stand for that for one
second and I don't think Britain would
have behaved in that way and I would
just say to the United States I'm
someone who is the strongest supporter
of the special relationship I think in a
very uncertain world the democracies of
the world need to stand together but if
we're going to be an alliance you know
we need to treat each other like allies
and that is not happening so you think
the u.s. is not treating us as an ally a
man I think they should send an sakuni's
back we are alongside America the
country that has done the most to stand
up for the rule of law across the world
and we need to show an example in cases
like this okay now we're expecting a
reshuffle next week Johnson picked up
the phones you offered you a cabinet job
would you go back do you know Sophie I
am so relieved this is the first
reshuffle that there's been for a decade
where I haven't had to wait by my phone
and think about my future if you may
remember I was involved in that in a
famous reshuffle in 2018 where Theresa
May wanted to move me from my job as
health secretary in the middle of an NHS
went to crisis and I I said I wasn't
prepared to go you've got a reputation
haven't you about being a difficult
customer when it comes to reshuffles
because she refused Boris Johnson's job
after last time as well don't you well
um they're often very specific reasons
but I actually think Boris has made an
excellent start as Prime Minister I want
him to be successful I don't rule out in
in the future but some way away serving
him because I want him to be a success
but during that leadership campaign I
realized that I had been in the cabinet
for every hour that my three kids have
been alive because I've been in the
cabinet for nine years and my oldest is
nine and I thought this is a period I'm
a bit more time for my kids
at one time for my constituency have
also been very long suffering so I shall
be very happily not waiting by the phone
this time so you've been better dad as a
result what do you have to ask my things
about that at least I've been giving
them more time and and of course you
famously ran against Boris Johnson to be
leader of the Conservative Party and
Prime Minister is there anything you'd
have done differently if it was you in
number 10 now of course we're we're
different people there are lots of
things that I would have done
differently for example but one thing
that I hope would have been exactly the
same is that I am a strong supporter of
hs2 and I very much hope in fact I would
go for eight just three HS for I as
someone who lived in Japan
I've always been ashamed of a state of
our railways and frankly anywhere else
you go the world they have decent
railways which had proper investment and
if we want to be a a modern 21st century
country then we've it's time we sort of
that out so I very much hope we go full
speed ahead on that one okay well not
long to find out if we do Jeremy Hunt
thank you very much for being on the
program this morning Thank You Sophie